after eight seasons Game of Thrones has
finally come to an end in an episode
called the Iron Throne here are 22
things you might have missed in the
series finale and warning spoilers
archive for the show's very last credit
sequence they changed yet again this
time there was no lying above the Iron
Throne showing that the Lannisters reign
has ended and while the red keep is
still shown as standing other parts of
King's Landing have been destroyed we
see a crack in the floor in the credits
that we see later in the episode as
Tyrion walks through the rubble Daenerys
stands in the ruins of King's Landing
overlooking her massive army the image
almost directly mirrors this shot from
Lord of the Rings the two towers as
Saruman overlooks his army before
commanding them to march to Helms Deep
like Daenerys Saruman also descended
into madness in that speech she
specifically speaks to the Dothraki
saying you kept all your promises to me
you killed my enemies and their iron
suits you tore down their stone houses
you gave me the Seven Kingdoms she's
referring to the original promise Khal
Drogo gave danny's unborn son in season
1
Danny recalls this speech in season six
when she names all the Dothraki her
blood riders in Tyrion cell John repeats
the words of Aemon Targaryen the maester
of the Nights Watch Amon offered this
piece of wisdom when John was
considering deserting the Nights Watch
in order to come to Rob's aid sooner or
later in every man's life there comes a
day when it is not easy a day when he
must choose in retrospect
his words sound pretty pathetic Danny's
premonition in the season 2 finale Valar
morghulis finally came to fruition in it
she walks through a ruined throne room
that's blanketed in snow in episode 6
however she actually touched the throne
in the vision she did not the Lord of
the Rings comparisons were plenty
moments after John murders Daenerys
drogon flies in and it mourning burns
the Iron Throne to a crisp this is yet
another instance mirroring Lord of the
Rings as pointed out by Johanna Robinson
of Vanity Fair the Iron Throne is
similar to the One Ring an object of
absolute power that is absolutely
corrupting in this instance Daenerys was
like Gollum looking wide-eyed when she
finally obtains what she's been
searching for all her life and then like
the One Ring the throne is destroyed by
fire melting in front of our eyes taking
Daenerys along with it as the Starks
stand at the King's Landing docks and
prepare to go their separate ways
grey worm also departs he's heading
towards naath which is where Masson day
is from right before the Battle of
Winterfell and a few episodes before
Masson day's tragic death grey worm
tells Masson day that after the war ends
that he would like to leave Westeros and
asks her where she would want to go she
responds that she would like to go see
North again I'd like to see the beaches
again where I'm kept his promise
but had to make the journey alone the
Starks go their separate ways John to
the north Sansa back to Winterfell and
Arya somewhere out west to lands unknown
to Westeros see this was yet another
Lord of the Rings parallel The Return of
the King in
with Frodo Gandalf and other characters
sailing away to the undying lands the
two big farewells are visual and
emotional mirrors of one another and
speaking of which Ari has had the urge
to explore what's west of Westeros since
at least season six when she had this
conversation with the Braavosi actress
lady crane well he go s was his East the
Westeros is West but was west of
Westeros I don't know nobody does
so there all the maps to the edge of the
world baby I'd like to see that the
Great Council meets in the dragon pit to
decide tarry ins fate and who will rule
Westeros among the people on the council
Samwell Tarly Edmure Tully Robin Arryn
yon Royce sir Brienne of Tarth ser Davos
Seaworth ginjury Baratheon Yara Greyjoy
an unnamed prince of Dorne and then
Sansa Arya and bran there are also a few
unidentified Lords when possibly from
the westerland's and another might be
from a lesser-known house in the reach
Edmure Tully Catelyn Stark's younger
brother has provided some of the most
memorable moments of comic relief on the
show and this episode was no different
most memorably in season 3 he tried to
light his father's funeral pyre and
couldn't hit it
breanne is the new Lord Commander of the
Kingsguard and she has a raven sigil on
her armor representing bran the new king
we see Brienne riding in the white book
a book with records of the deeds of all
the members of the Kingsguard Brienne
read Jaime's page back in season four
episode 4 thereafter known as the
Kingslayer it's the duty of the Lord
commands to fill those pages there's
still room left in mine now that
Brianna's Lord Commander she fills
Jaime's pages with the rest of his life
and his death we get to see exactly what
Brienne writes in these pages about
Jaime we see her refer to the loot train
battle from season 7 episode 4 as the
Battle of gold Road which is a new name
for that battle and a better one at the
small council meeting Sam presents
Tyrion with a Song of Ice and Fire
it's a history of wars after King Robert
written by archmaester ebro's Sam says
he helped with the title this is a
callback to season 7 I'm not writing a
chronicle of the wars following the
death of King Robert the first so he can
sit on the shelf
unread but you don't like the title what
would you call it that possibly
something a bit more poetic when the new
small council assembles bran says or
soon there won't be no more coin sir
Davos who's master of ships corrects him
by saying anymore
this is particularly funny because when
we first met Davos he couldn't read he
was taught by Shireen Stannis
Baratheon's daughter the first [ __ ]
tonight in Tyrians final moment on the
show he says he brought a jackass and a
honeycomb into a brothel but here's the
thing we've all heard this joke before
tyrion first attempted to tell it in his
confession to liza
erin in season 1 before she cuts him off
i was a jackass and a honeycomb into a
brothel he then starts telling the same
joke to grey worm in Masson day in
season 6 episode 3 Oathbreaker before
he's interrupted once again I've once
walked into a brothel with a honeycomb
in a jackass the madam says
well it looks like we'll never hear the
punchline now Tyrion's fussy chair
rearranging is a habit left over from
Tywin small council meetings which were
memorable for passive-aggressive moves
like this
[Music]
Santa's coronation dress represents the
independence of the north it has a
pattern of a weirwood tree which grows
in the forests up north the symbolism
reminds us just how much she's evolved
since logging for the South in season
one santa's crown also resembles one of
Circe's crowns especially from the back
it suggests that Sansa took on the best
of Circe's queenly qualities a lot of
fans voiced their disappointment after
Jon parted ways with ghost in Episode
four without so much as petting his wolf
goodbye that episode's director David
Nutter explained that cgi considerations
were the real reason behind Jon's abrupt
send-off
luckily the visual effects team was able
to pull together this last shot of Jon
and ghosts reunion the final shot of the
show is Jon Snow walking off beyond the
wall with the wildlings through the
woods the show ends in the exact same
place as it began the pilot episode
begins with a group of men from the
Nights Watch going beyond the wall where
they encounter dead wildlings and then a
white Walker now they are free to walk
beyond the wall with no whites or white
walkers in sight in a mistake seen
across the world a coffee cup
accidentally ended up in season 8
episode 4 the last of the Starks and
unfortunately it happened again in the
finale during the council meeting you
can spot not one but two water bottles
that were left behind one by Sam and one
by does
do we miss anything let us know in the
comments
[Music]